[Music]
what was that moment like for you
because
i would fall on the floor well that's
exactly what i did i fell on the ball
not only that i fell on the floor but i
knocked over my chair
and then i collapsed on the ground this
is the olympics
of modeling for us leina looks like a
champion on her sports illustrated cover
as she sends a powerful message to the
trans community and the rest of the
world
did you ever honestly imagine that your
career would bring you to this point
honestly no there's not many trans
representations especially of color in
the fashion world
so the fact that we have literally
said forget about that we're just gonna
put you on the cover
and be the embodiment of what exactly we
need in the world
i think that was kind of like
are we really having this moment yes we
are laina joins two other incredible
cover stars
rapper megan the stallion and tennis
queen naomi osaka
and if lena looks familiar well you also
may have caught her in the final season
of pose alongside
mj rodriguez you just
keep trying mj has made history of her
own becoming the first trans woman to
ever be nominated for a major acting
award at the upcoming emmys
this september mj is a powerful powerful
woman
i remember seeing her on the first
episode of season one of pose
and i text her right away and i said
what you are doing is going to change
the world
do you feel like trans individuals are
finally getting
some of the respect that they deserve
just 10 years ago
the idea of being a trans person in any
way shape or form
and public eye was non-existent now
we are at a time when we can't stop
talking we cannot stop winning we cannot
stop
reaching to the top of the mountaintop
and that's exactly where we deserve to
be
and if anyone is tired of this baby we
just getting started so
get ready